I am in the National Advanced Driving Simulator
at the University of Iowa.
It's used to test drivers' reactions
in a controlled, repeatable environment
and also to test things that would
be unsafe in the real world.
- Tom's currently in the
simulator, undergoing a study
to look at driver response
to unintended acceleration.
The vehicle is going
to accelerate quickly
without any input from Tom,
as if it were malfunctioning.
Tom's going to have to identify that this event is going on
and press the brake very quickly
to bring the car under control.
GPS: Turn left at the next intersection.
Whoa...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That was terrifying!
But there's a question
I want to answer here.
Recently, I did a video while driving.
And it was on a dead straight road
with very little traffic,
and I always felt in control of the vehicle.
But was I?
Is it actually dangerous to talk
into a camera while driving?
So, I'm going to spend 15 minutes
in this simulator, distracted,
trying to give this monologue
to that camera.
And I'm also going to spend
15 minutes in here, not distracted
just driving, and putting my
full attention on the road,
and the team here
are going to analyse my results
and tell me how I've done.
And given I was just doing 35 in a 25,
probably not that great.
- The National Advanced Driving Simulator
was built to recreate
the most realistic
driving experience possible anywhere.
It has a real vehicle cab in it.
We can swap different
vehicle cabs, in and out.
The motion base can travel 64 feet
in the X and Y directions
and these are basically steel
belts that are connected to
large drives on either end and then,
the hexapod portion of the
simulator is hydraulic,
that allows us to experience
roll, pitch and yaw.
We also have a turntable that can
turn 330 degrees in either direction.
Overall, it has 13 independent
degrees of freedom.
We have absolute control
of what time of day it is.
We have control over
the weather and traffic.
- And yes, the graphics might not be up to
modern video game standards,
but after a few minutes in here,
with all the motion,
your brain just accepts that you're driving.
- Very broadly, we are
interested in studying the relation
between the driver and the vehicle
to improve safety,
so that encompasses things like
driver impairment, driver drowsiness,
distraction or intoxication.
So we bring drivers in,
actually give them a
large dose of alcohol,
get them in the simulator and
we can see how they perform.
We've also compared that
to things like cannabis,
so some of the first studies
with cannabis and driving
have been done in
the simulator here as well.
As Tom is driving in the simulator,
talking to the video camera,
I would expect to see him missing
certain information in the driving scene.
Generally, we find that
interactions that take the
driver's eyes off the road
tend to be the worst but,
even in situations where the
driver's looking straight ahead,
if their attention is pulled to another task,
like talking to a video camera,
that can also increase distraction and cause
the driver to miss certain things.
If the driver crashes, they
essentially move through
the vehicle or the pedestrian
that they collided with,
so, we don't simulate the
dynamics of the crash,
but we are recording that they crashed.
We know the velocity of that crash.
We know how severe that
crash would have been.
- So, how did I do?
- About as well as we would have predicted.
Let me pull up an example, here.
A vehicle is going to drive
through an intersection.
You actually have the red stop sign.
- Yeah, I didn't see the stop sign, did I?
- Completely missed it.
- Whoa, just did not see that.
The thing is, I'm actually
looking at the road, there.
I'm actually... but I'm not
thinking about the road,
because I'm too busy thinking
about what my next line is.
- Exactly, we would call this
inattentional blindness.
This is when your
attention is off the road,
even though your eyes are there.
You're missing information
that's out in the environment.
- Wow.
- So, we saw quite a bit of
swerving at the beginning of your drive,
you had some trouble
controlling your speed.
You were going about 35
through a 25 school zone.
Textbook case of distracted driving.
- So, I basically, shouldn't
film while driving.
- Generally speaking, yes.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much to everyone at the
National Advanced Driving Simulator
at the University of Iowa.
Pull down the description or click
the link on screen for more about them.
All the pedestrians here are just suicidal.
All of them.
This is not a stop sign.
I can just take this.
Whoa, no I can't.
You're coming in from the right.
Probably shouldn't check
my phone while I'm driving.